have a clear understanding of the logic  behind bioinformatics analysis in the  context of cutting-edge research  projects and see how data science  methods can be used to study biological  phenomena in conclusion you will also be  able to plan how to take what you have  learned and apply it to an independent  research project using tools and methods  that we cover so what is bioinformatics  it is a convergence of biology and data  where both are equally important as we  will see in the next few slides  who uses bioinformatics and who is it  for the answer might have previously  been statisticians computer scientists  or engineers but the truth is that today  more and more biologists and clinicians  are expected to understand as well as  handle their own data to publish and  succeed in both basic and translational  research projects in fact biology itself  is rapidly acquiring the character of a  data science